[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance Donald Trump America's
foremost Richard Nixon impersonator just
as Nixon could not stop bringing up
Watergate to insist everybody should
stop talking about Watergate
ensuring everybody kept talking about
Watergate Trump brought up Russia and
the Russian Facebook ads and the steel
dossier six times last weekend to insist
everything was discredited and a plot
and everybody should stop talking about
Russia ensuring everybody will keep
talking about Russia and just as it
never dawned on Nixon that if his
administration paid the legal fees or
paid anything else to men and women
accused of or suspected of committing
possible crimes on his behalf or just
witnessing them the payments could
themselves become their own problem and
help cost him his presidency Trump has
reportedly set out to do almost exactly
the same thing the payments first the
Republican National Committee confirms
it has paid four hundred and thirty
thousand dollars worth of legal fees for
Trump and his son Uday I'm sorry Don Jr
Axios comm quotes a White House source
who says Trump won't repay the
Republicans for that but has instead
pledged to pay the same amount quoting
Axia's source to defray the costs of
legal fees for his associates including
former and current White House aides
what's that called again when there's a
criminal investigation and one possible
perpetrator gives money to other
possible perpetrators or witnesses in
the same case on whatever pretext what
does that sound like to you when John
Dean went into the Oval Office on March
21st 1973 to try to scare Richard Nixon
into calling off the Watergate cover-up
he explained that Watergate burglar
Howard hunt was blackmailing the White
House for among other things legal fees
this was when Dean spoke his famous
words we have a cancer within close to
the presidency that's growing and said
these people are going to cost a million
dollars over the next two years
Nixon John Dean tells me now had long
before proposed to John Ehrlichman and
Bob Haldeman that they should establish
a legal defense fund for the water
burglars publicly announcing that
everybody deserved a lawyer but instead
of bringing that idea back or instead of
saying we have to stop this cover-up
instead of deflating the most memorable
quote from the White House tapes what
Nixon actually told John was quote we
could get that you could get a million
dollars and you could get it in cash
I know where it could be gotten in
today's case of Trump and Russia we know
where it could be gotten from Donald
Trump's pocket holy crap he may manage
to clean up the legalities here but this
is still tantamount to hush money and
what's worse is it might work except
there's one guy who won't hush who every
time the Trump Russia scandal fades into
the background keeps reminding us about
Russia and the steel dossier and the
Facebook ads and all the rest and that
one guy is Donald Trump in just over
thirty four hours starting Friday
morning Trump tweeted six times in
reference to Russia in them twice
referring to the steel dossier twice to
the Facebook ads twice to Hillary
Clinton twice erroneously two people
taking the fifth amendment and once
implying that the FBI and the Democrats
and the Russians made the steel dossier
up in other words don't believe this
nonsense that somebody in this country
could have colluded with the Russians to
sabotage our election instead believe
this other nonsense that somebody in
this country could have colluded with
the Russians to sabotage our election
the I'm rubber you're glue presidential
defense in a previous commentary I
suggested that Trump like a desperate
child has to keep bringing the subject
up keep shouting those keywords that he
should never speak again
Russia hacking Assange Putin until he
can presumably convince himself that he
has convinced everyone everywhere that
none of it is true he could not make it
look more like he is covering up
something something horrifying if he
hung a sign around his neck reading
cover-up it is madness and it will
destroy him that previous commentary was
from the 10th of January and every time
since then when the investigation or the
story has seemed to droop
Trump has revivified it firing Comey
meeting with Russians in the Oval Office
and he fired Co me threatening Comey
with apparently non-existent tapes
weighing in on or reportedly dictating
his son's misleading denial about the
bezel nets kya meeting and now legal
fees and/or hush money for possible
defendants or witnesses in the Russian
scandal and six tweets alluding to
Russia and - specifically about the
steel dossier the steel dossier which
has that part about the mmm tape the
tape about which Trump kept telling
Comey he needed to be cleared you saw
what John Schindler the former NSA and
Naval War College figure wrote about the
dossier and the moon tape right though
the specific quotes PP tape claim is
viewed with derision by most Western
spies who know the Russians it's very
likely that the Kremlin possesses
comprar Matt on the president senior
intelligence sources from several
countries have confirmed to me that
unpleasant videos of trump exist
unpleasant so Trump keeps bringing up
Russia
why on earth it is imperative to
remember a little noted story from the
New York Times that Trump's attorneys
particularly the guy with the mustache
Ty Cobb the genius who held an extensive
conversation with another Trump lawyer
about the case over lunch at a popular
Washington Bistro without ever noticing
that the guy at the next table from them
was a reporter from The Times
this ty cobb guy has reportedly kept
telling trump that if he cooperates with
robert Muller's investigation trump will
get what he most desires an official
public permanent everlasting statement
that he's not being investigated about
Russia and by extension that the steel
dossier and the thing in the steel
dossier the mm-hmm tape are not true the
topic Trump cannot leave alone cannot
quit while he's merely behind and not
yet you know impeached four hundred and
thirty thousand dollars for other
people's patern ease and for their sake
let's hope they get better attorneys
than Ty Cobb
resist remove piece this all might be
explained by the title of my new book
Trump is effing crazy is now available
in stores and online and without a
prescription